Elizabeth starts out five miles away
from school and walks away from school
at three miles per hour so she's already
five miles away and she's going to walk
even further away at three miles per
hour
the table below shows how far some other
students are from school at various
times each person is moving at a
constant speed starting at time is equal
to zero which students started out
farther from school than Elizabeth
select all that apply so essentially we
need to figure out where these students
were at time equals zero so we know
where they were at time one two and
three and so let's think about their
rate towards or away from school so and
remember this is distance from school so
for as we increase as we go from our one
to our two Gordon gets two miles closer
so his distance to school is decreasing
so where was he at time equals zero I'll
put time equals zero up here because I
don't have these actually I'll put it
right here I'll try to squeeze it into
the chart so where was he at time equals
zero well he would have been two miles
further so he would have been six miles
away notice it's consistent in the first
hour he would have gotten two miles
closer to school then the next hour he
would have gotten two miles even closer
and in the third hour he actually gets
two miles closer and he actually gets to
school so Gordon started out six miles
away at T equals zero so Gordon did
start out farther from school than
Elizabeth so we can circle Gordon he
meets the conditions I was think about
Giovanni so at time one he's five miles
away from school that at time two or
time or at one hour he's five miles away
after two hours he's six miles away so
he's getting further from school so this
is a plus one and then after another
hour he's seven miles away so every hour
that goes by he's a mile further he's
going one mile
our away from school so where was he at
time equal zero well he would have been
a mile closer to school relative to time
equal one so he would have been four
miles away so he did not start out
farther than Elizabeth who started out
five miles away now let's look at Hanna
Hanna at every time is just fought
exactly five miles away from school so
she's napping or something she is not
actually moving so Hanna didn't she
started out a you know napping at
exactly the same distance as Elizabeth
but she did not start out farther from
school than Elizabeth so Hanna does not
meet the cry the criteria now let's look
at Alberto at time equals one he is nine
miles from school and then after one
hour he gets a mile and a half he gets a
mile and a half further from school
after another hour he gets a mile and a
half a mile and a half even further so
where was he at time equals zero well he
would have been a mile and a half closer
to school so nine minus 1.5 is he would
have been seven and a half miles away so
even though he even though he's going
away from well he definitely started
further from school than Elizabeth
Elizabeth started out five miles away
Alberto started off seven and a half
miles away and it's going even further
and further and further
so the two students that started out
farther from school than Elizabeth are
Gordon and Alberto